I'm super excited to
introduce Jennifer Rexford.
Jenn, [LAUGH] as she
allowed me to call her.
So she's the winner of
the ACM Athena Lecture Award.
It's Athena Lecture.
And which is kind of
the Turing Award for women.
So this is a really,
really big deal.
And, but of course, this is not
the only award that she has won.
She won the Grace,
ACM Grace Hopper award in 2005.
She's an ACM fellow,
she is a fellow of the American
Association for Arts and
Sciences and a member of the
National Academy of Engineering.
So she got her PhD from
the University of Michigan,
as it turns out in the same
year that I got my PhD, so
I'm not gonna comment on that.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> For protecting my
own privacy.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
then she went to industry to
work at AT&T and Bell Labs.
And Albert is here,
and so they go back.
But of course, she has
a number of other Microsoft
relationships, so
her students are always welcome,
and they do come, and
we're very grateful for that.
This is not her first talk.
She gave a summer school
on networking in India.
And as I just heard,
she visited Victor's group
nine years ago, right?
>> Yes.
>> Now, after AT&T, she's on
the faculty at Princeton,
and in her work she's
kind of a pioneer of
software-defined networks.
And again, your co-inventor
of OpenFlow, and
I have a personal history with
that, because when I was at ETH,
we bought a huge pile
of Arista switches.
And the big defining factor was
that they were OpenFlow and
that we could program them.
Before that,
she also worked on PGP,
which I also at some
point taught at ETH.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> And one
of the most interesting,
as I was googling and searching
around, she has a page with all
the advice that she give
like PhD students and so on.
And there was also one of
our PowerPoint text which is
interesting for me which was
industry versus academia.
And this is my last thing.
You went from industry
to academia and
the PowerPoint explains why.
I went from academia
to industry.
So we'll cross our
stories later today.
>> We'll call it even.
>> Yeah, okay [LAUGH].
So thanks for coming and
yeah, and please, we are all-
>> Thanks so much for
the introduction, and it's great
to be among so many old friends.
So what I wanna do is give
a talk that I've given at CITCON
our main networking
conference a few months ago.
And it's about interdisciplinary
research in computer networking.
And what I wanna do is give you
a little bit of background of
how I came into this style of
research, and formed a lot by my
experiences at AT&T, walk
through a few example projects
that I've worked on since
going to Princeton.
And then end with some,
sort of advice for
people, particularly young
people that are considering
doing interdisciplinary work,
both about the joys and
some of the risks of doing
that style of research,
particularly from
an academic perspective.
So just to give a kind
of a little context.
To think all of us are living
in a really exciting time in
computer networking.
Really, the Internet is
an invention that escaped from
the lab during our life times to
become a global communications
infrastructure, growing
from this.
It's a really global
communications infrastructure
that's increasingly critical for
a huge number of applications
that affect our daily lives.
And it's not only
a critical infrastructure,
it's one with near
constant innovation.
Innovation in the applications
and services that run on top,
on the kinds of machines that
connect to it at the edge, and
the kind of physical
infrastructure that the network
itself runs over.
So, society critically
depends on it.
It's in a constant
state of churn.
And so a really simple grand
challenge that we really all,
I think need to think about, not
just as networking people but
as computer scientists probably,
is that we need to build
computer networks that are
worthy of the trust that society
increasingly places in them.
And that really just
unpack that a little bit,
means they needs
to be performant.
They need to be reliable,
secure, protect user privacy,
be fair, efficient,
enable the different autonomous
entities on the Internet to work
somewhat independently
to be cost effective.
And even reason about
the inherent tensions between
all of these goals.
And so, I would argue,
to do that, we really need to
build much stronger intellectual
foundations for how we design
and operate networks, so
that we can build better
real world networks.
And also, in particular, build
ones that are robust to the
constant innovation taking place
above, next to, and below them.
And the main point I wanna make
in this talk is that networking
researchers really can't do this
alone because the intellectual
challenges are so
significant and
the societal implications so
broad.
And that's why, really,
an interdisciplinary approach
to solving these problems is so
critical.
And so what I wanna talk about
is bringing together these sort
of big, hairy, audacious
research problems that arise in
computer networking together
with effective solution
techniques that borrow from
other parts of computer science
and other areas of
engineering and mathematics.
And this sort of style of
research was something that was
born out of my experiences
in the nine years I spent in
Albert's group at AT&T, where
the group we were in really
connected the people within the
research organization doing work
in algorithms, optimization and
statistics with the people
that were really holding
the network together.
AT&T's commercial
backbone network,
together to be able to take the
problems that they were facing
in their day to day live
running the network and
to bring those problems
out of the sort of
great details in the domain
details that networking people
would be comfortable with in the
problems, there can really be
a tact in a rigorous way
from other disciplines.
And so in the work in Albert's
lab, the work started before I
joined, but I think the premise
of a lot of the work was that
the network wasn't designed
to be managed, right?
Internet protocols
are really not designed
with a network operator in mind.
If anything, network management
and commercial interests
were anathema to the early
designers of the Internet.
And so the idea that came out
from Albert and his group really
worked on was the idea that we
could bolt on network management
on top by having a sort
of control loop for
measuring the network to
know that offered traffic,
the topology, anomalies, taking
place in the network and so on.
And feed that into systems
that model, analyze,
optimize and so on.
And use those results to go
back and actually affect change
in the network, to block
attacks, to re-route traffic,
to plan for the future by
following this controller.
So there was a lot of work I was
involved in in the nine years I
was at AT&T.
And a lot of it was able to be
both academically interesting,
and deployed in practice
because it was sort of close to
those domain details, and yet
abstracted a bit from them
enough that we could solve
them in more rigorous ways.
So at the time that I left AT&T,
the one frustration I had with
this style of work was that for
good reason we were really
focusing on taking the existing
network equipment as a given.
This was pragmatic.
We didn't really have a choice.
Even AT&T is a major purchase
of network equipment,
didn't get to control the code
that ran inside the box,
let alone the hardware inside.
And so pragmatically,
it was really difficult to do
much of anything if you wanted
to do something that required
changing the equipment.
But when I went to Princeton, I
was interested in taking a step
back and revisiting this control
loop and the problems associated
with it assuming I could
change the network.
And there was already at
the time starting to be
signs of an interest in making
networks more programmable,
including work that Albert Dave
Moths, myself, and others worked
on at AT&T that was a part of
this sort of great movement
towards software defined
networking over the last decade.
But more generally, I also
just wanted to engage with
the broader set of colleagues
in different disciplines on
problems that I hadn't been
able to tackle the way I wanted
because of having an arm held
behind my back by the Legacy
equipment.
So what I wanted to talk about
are three example projects that
I worked on since
coming to Princeton.
They're kind of are part of a
stack of protocols, if you will,
for running the network.
The first looking at
higher-level policies,
making it easier for network
administrators to describe what
they want the network to do, and
to synthesize the configuration
of the network from it.
One level lower to allow
the distributed collection of
routers in the network to figure
out what is the right way
to send traffic by
solving together a single
central optimization problem.
And then finally
getting the data out of
the underlying devices
That we need to make sound
decisions about the network.
And then we'll describe these
in chronological order.
So actually the middle
project took place first.
I'm going to talk
about that one first.
But in each of these,
what I'm going to do is talk
about the problem we looked at.
Kind of a brief synopsis
of the research results.
And a little bit of the human
side of the lesson,
how the collaboration worked.
So in each of these projects
there was a set of other people
involved in
programming languages,
in optimization theory, or in
theoretical computer science in
the area of compact
data structure.
And I want to say a little bit
about how those collaborations
happened, and
what made them possible.
And at the end I'll talk
a little bit more in anonymized
terms about less successful
interdisciplinary projects
I've been involved in, and what
went wrong in those projects.
But just to start at the middle,
a lot of the work that we did
at AT&T focused on optimization.
Right we're trying to optimize
the resources inside the network
to the prevailing traffic.
And I became very interested.
If we were to start with
optimization in mind
from the beginning.
If we weren't forced to solve
the optimization problem
the network itself induced,
could we actually design
the network to be inherently
easier to optimize?
And so I engaged with
a colleague of mine
then at Princeton,
Mung Chiang, who is an expert
in network optimization.
And he has been working along
with a number of other people
on the idea that protocols
are distributed optimizer's.
That protocols are themselves
a distributed algorithm for
solving and optimization problem
and that we can turn the crank
the other way, we can start with
an optimization problem and
generate the protocol.
That corresponds to it.
So the tipping off point was the
projects that I had been working
on at at&t just before joining.
Well, we were
really thinking from the network
operator's perspective,
how to optimize the flow of
traffic inside the network.
There we couldn't
change the end hosts,
we couldn't change the routers.
The end hosts are sending
traffic in whatever way they're
gonna send.
The routers are computing
shortest paths and
the network operator can only
observed the offered traffic and
tweak the routing protocols so
that the routers in doing their
own computational shortest paths
might compute sensible paths to
the network that balance load.
But the more general
question is,
how much traffic should be
sent and over what path?
And what is the right division
of labor between the senders,
who are adapting
their sending rates,
the routers that
are computing the paths, and
the network operator that's
trying to minimize congestion.
The way that this
was being done.
At the time was essentially
without any cooperation between
these three parties, and
hosts, using the TCP or
Transmission Control Protocol,
would adapt their sending
rates based on observations
of network congestion.
When your packets get through
quickly without getting lost,
send more.
When they get lost or
delayed, send less in order to
avoid overloading the network.
And the network in turn,
with the operator's help,
would be monitoring the overall
network wide traffic.
And reoptimizing the routing
to direct traffic over less
congested paths.
And so there's a bit of
a control loop happening here if
these two systems
operate independently.
Congestion control is changing
the traffic in response to
observed congestion.
Traffic engineering is changing
the routes in response to
observed congestion.
And they're each optimizing
a slightly different thing, and
so several things go wrong here.
There's often a time scale
separation where traffic
engineering was taking place on
the time scale of hours or day.
So there was often slow
adaptation to decouple these two
control loops, and also sort
of a one size fits all view.
Where the network administrator
would be trying to, in general,
just minimize congestion, rather
than realizing the different
applications over the network
might have different notions
of utility for what they
want the network to do.
So we took inspiration from
a body of work that came out of
work from Frank Kelly and
Stephen Lowe and
others, looking at protocols
as distributed optimizers.
And so I'm gonna walk you
really briefly through
the basic idea network.
It focused a lot on TCP itself.
So the idea is that the
transmission control protocol
is solving
an optimization problem.
Where traffic is being sent
over a route at a particular
rate from a particular sender.
And the idea is that sender
wants to send traffic
at a higher rate to get
higher utility, but
with diminishing returns.
So as the sending
rate is higher and
is delivered over the network,
the user's happier and happier.
But they're the most happy when
they go from getting nothing to
getting a little bit more, and
gradually there's diminishing
returns as they get higher and
higher bandwidth.
This is sort of a concave
curve of utility.
And the beautiful work that
Steven and Frank Kelly did and
others was to recognize
that what TCP is doing,
even though the early designers
of TCP didn't realized it,
were solving a utility
maximization problem.
Where you're essentially trying
to maximize the total utility
over all senders
subject to these terms.
And subject to constraints on
the capacities of the like.
In other words, if we have two
flows, one and two, they're
gonna have to share that link
l that has some capacity cl.
And they should do so
in a way where they maximize
the total utility across the two
users giving each of them
the bandwidth whoever needs it
most, relative to the utility.
>> What year was this work?
>> This would have been back,
let's see,
around the early 2000s.
>> Yeah, cuz in 99, 2000, we
>> I chaired an isat study
looking at future models on the
internet and Scott and the whole
gang was saying, don't touch and
don't think about TCP IP.
We don't know how it works,
if you try to do
coordinated control,
going to mess things up.
So let's just go with
the lightweight approach, and
that was kind of the theme back
then, stay away, hands off You
know, the cross at a distance
don't optimize, just go away.
And I guess there's
a change in there.
>> Yeah, yeah.
I think in the beggining it
changed in a way of being
reversed engineering.
Was like, hey we have this sort
of cottage industry of various
versions of TCP, all named
after geographic locations.
TCP Madison, etc.
All of these were eventually
reverse-engineered to fall in
this framework.
It's actually a really
beautiful body of work, and
they all differ in exactly what
shape that utility function has.
And there's a really
beautiful connection to
the notion of alpha fair utility
functions in network economics.
And all the different variants
of TCP that are prominent have
been translated into
what number alpha
Best describes
the utility function.
It's actually quite lovely.
And I don't think
it's a coincidence.
The hackers, if you will,
that got TCP working without
the benefit of this theory,
were doing something based on
intuition that kinda mimics it.
But it's really lovely that
there's sort of a collapsing of
the literature on TCP end
of this nice framework.
So the basic idea at the time
I joined Princeton a number of
people were starting to turn
the crank the other way right?
Can we start with this
definition of utility functions
and generate new
versions of TCP?
And Steven Lowe
generated one called Fast
that gave TCP for really long
distance networks where you have
very slow feedback coming back
from the network and so on.
So the jumping off point for
me in Mung was to think well
what if we wanted to control
not only the sending rate but
also the path?
So we wanted to solve the entire
traffic engineering problem in
a unified way.
So what we started with was
very much the same idea.
The only thing is I was given
an extra degree of freedom,
instead of controlling the
sending rate on a given path.
We have the ability to control
sending rates on multiple paths
on behalf of a single sender.
So we still want to maximize
the same notion of utility, but
the routing itself
is a variable.
So there might be let's say 2
paths through the network for
this sender and
I have the option to set the
rates on both of these paths so
that the total utility Is
defined by the sum of them.
And I wanna, again, be able to
arbitrate who gets access to
which paths, and
at what rate, collectively.
So, think of this as trying,
now,
to solve the traffic
engineering, routing, and
congestion control problem
in a single, unified way.
And so, what did we do?
Well, we used the same
kind of optimization,
decomposition techniques that
the previous work on TCP had
used, to translate that single
central optimization problem
into a distributed solution.
And the form that it takes,
is that every link
computes a price, based on
its own local observed load.
Less in indication of
the amount of loss for example,
taking place on this link
because a link is over capacity.
Imagine sending up that
feedback to the sender and
the sender will saw the local
optimization problem to update
the path rates.
Basic idea, think of it as
I wanna send more because I
get more utility when I do but
the more I send the higher
the price I pay because the
price I pay is the load I send.
Times the price of the pathenon.
And so if my path is expensive,
I'm gonna send a little bit
less, because I'm only getting a
little bit of marginal increase
in utility as I send more and
I'm paying a higher price.
So every link is locally
computing prices.
Every sender is locally solving
an optimization problem to find
the sweet spot, between sending
more to get more utility, and
sending less to
pay a lower price.
Yeah.
>> How sensitive
are these solutions and
parameters to assumptions
about the utility curves?
Do you measure utility directly,
do you measure the curves
directly and use them or
do you just assume the curves?
>> We're designing
with a particular
utility function in mind.
>> So
how sensitive of what you do
to the functions of that curve?
>> It is relatively sensitive.
You wanna pick something
that has the shape you want,
because as long as the
optimization problem's convex-
>> No, I mentioned convex as
the beginning-
>> Yeah.
>> But when it comes to
the parameters of the curve it's
just very sensitive to that,
and you have to check that,
and actually we just
go with the assumption
>> So there is a sensitivity.
I'm not sure I'm getting quite
at your question but there-
>> Sensitivity to the
>> There is a sensitivity
in convergence time.
That was one and I'll come
to that in a few slide.
The sort of brute force kind
of approach of just doing
decomposition and running ends
up being quite sensitive to,
it often converts very slowly.
Even though it is sort of
preferably optimal and
will converge,
it might converge very slowly.
And so we found this sort of
straightforward application
of this technique didn't produce
effective results by itself.
So the basic idea, then, is now
we've got a single optimization
problem that's being solved
by each of the links and
each of the senders doing
its own local computation.
So the next question we
cared about was, well,
what if we have multiple
classes of traffic,
each with different
performance goals.
So you might imagine some
traffic cares about throughput.
Some cares about latency,
and you might have different
functions for
those different traffic classes.
And you might imagine that the
links have a share of them with
allocated the one and
a with allocated to the other.
Think of this as a green
virtual network for
the latency sensitive traffic,
and a red one for
the throughput
sensitive traffic.
And you might imagine
a straightforward
extension to the utility
function as you wanna maximize
the aggregate utility across
the two classes of traffic.
So again here,
we can turn that crank
of decomposing this optimization
problem now in two steps.
One that separates the two
utilities from one another.
Subject to the local
link capacity shares.
And a second on a longer
time scale that decides what
fraction of each link's capacity
should be devoted to each one.
Think of this as sort of
a form of adaptive network
virtualization.
The topology is virtualized but
the bandwidth allocation
between the two classes are
being dynamically adapted based
on who needs it more to be able
to achieve their utility goals.
So, again, same basic idea, that
now we can essentially design
the same protocol
we would have run,
had this delay sensitive, or
throughput sensitive traffic
been the only only traffic
class in the network.
But we can arbitrate between
them by dynamically deciding
what shares of them
would they each get.
So, that was sort
of the second step.
Now, I think for me,
the lessons here.
One was the idea that
protocol should be
solving a well-stated problem.
This sort of sounds obvious
in hindsight right, but
a lot of networking protocols
were designed without a really
clear specification of what
problem they were solving.
And in particular, what global
problem they were solving rather
than the local problem.
A particular sender
might be interested in.
And then to use techniques for
decomposing the problem.
This gives us, I think,
both a better understand of
how the protocols work and
when they work, and also
guarantees that come from that
on optimality, and
conversions, and so on.
But in practice as Erik's
question already hinted at that
isn't quite enough, the process
itself is inherently iterative.
We didn't really come to the
solutions we did in one step and
so there's sort of
a human lesson here and
then a few technical takeaways.
One I think of as sort of
research as decomposition
which is this is sort of
the way the work between Mung
and I would go.
I would say I need the network
to solve this problem,
he would say the math
is too hard.
And this is great for
Mung, because instead
of Mung going and
working on a hard math problem
he would turn back to me and
say change the problem so
the math is easy.
He liked to put it as, if you're
the professor and the student,
you write an easy exam, right?
So it was my job to figure
out if I could change
the constraints that I felt the
network would have to impose and
relax them in some way to
make the problem easier.
And then Mung would eventually
say thumbs up, it's convex,
I'm happy, we can apply standard
optimization techniques
to solve the problem now.
So the art in this
work was not the math.
Quite the opposite, the art was
in not making the math hard.
So just to give two examples of
where that concretely came up.
One was that we found when
we did the sort of standard
decomposition approach we did
get something that was optimal
and conversed, but it conversed
really, really slowly.
And so we actually changed the
utility function we were using
accordingly to make it a little
bit quicker in adapting to
congestion.
In particular, instead of
looking just at utility,
we also look at a penalty
function that penalize links
that were getting close
to their capacity.
This problem on the left,
maximizing utility was what
used to be congestion
control was doing.
Minimizing this penalty was
actually what the network
operators were doing.
In doing traffic engineering, so
there's sort of an interesting
coming full circle here,
that in some ways,
both sets of hackers were right.
Maximizing utility and
keeping a damper on congestion
both end up being important.
And once we decomposed
this problem,
we ended up with something that
not only provably optimal and
stable, but converged much,
much more quickly,
because it gave an early
warning when the network
was getting into
an unhappy place.
Rather than waiting for all
hell to break loose beforehand.
And a second example, when we're
looking at multiple classes of
traffic, I described it
as if there's sorta two
separate virtual networks each
with its own share of resources.
But when we started we
envisioned, there being one Q,
one capacity for the link and
the traffic mixing together.
But in practice that made
the optimization problem
impossible to decompose.
Because the utility of one
traffic class was really
intertwined with
utility of the other.
To put that in kinda
concrete terms,
delay sensitive traffic will
be suffering delays in queuing
because the throughput sensitive
traffic would drive the links to
very high levels of utilization.
And so, we found to get
the optimization problem to
decompose, we had to
have separate queues
on a longer time scale with
the scheduling of them changing
to accommodate who
needed more utility.
And that came out of just
observing that the math
was really hard if we didn't
make that separation.
So the perfect example where
Mung said can't do it but if we,
actually could separate this
through traffic classes and
make their utility functions
less dependent on some time
scale we can.
A sort of more human lesson
here is also anybody who's
ever been a graduate student
in this room knows that
research never works this way,
with faculty actually talking to
each other on a regular basis.
So you should already be quite
suspicious that I haven't told
you the whole story.
Which is of course, the student
in the room was critical,
because she was able to
connect with both of us and
to really wrangle us and
get enough expertise with both
topics, of network hardware and
software constrains as well as
the optimization techniques
involved to be able to actually
make this work happen.
Now, for me,
a great frustration,
this work happened
about 10 years ago,
is it was really hard to get it
deployed because again we were
still stuck with the problem I
mentioned at the beginning that
we can't change the equipment
inside the network.
So, we could to experiments,
we could do simulations,
but we couldn't deploy.
And now we're actually just
starting to have the kind of
programmable switch hardware.
And I'll talk more about these
kind of switching capabilities
a little later in the talk where
now it actually is possible to
deploy these techniques.
And I'm starting to work with
folks at AT&T, sort of then
coming full circle who are
interested in doing a deployment
of some of these ideas to see
if they might be suitable for
their backbone network.
So that's sort of the end of
the first part of the talk.
If we wanna maybe stop here,
if people have comments or
questions before I go on?
Yeah?
>> So you mentioned optimization
as being as the talent
you're looking for
to mix with networking.
But it seems it's a big third
bubble coming in in mechanism
design in economics, which is
kind of a different way of
thinking about distribution of
effort, and credit assignment,
and payment, and so on.
I'm curious if that's still
an area that's waiting,
pregnant with results
in this space, or?
>> Yeah,
that's a great question.
So, yes, I think so, and one
piece of work I don't have in
here that had that flavor was
looking at how the different
domains that make up
the Internet interact with one
another, because their economics
obviously play a direct role.
Entire autonomous systems,
entire networks,
are sort of rational actors.
>> Yeah.
>> Making best responses based
on what their neighbors do.
And there the language of game
theory is a beautiful fit
and it is.
>> Is it an area that is wide
open in the fifteen years
while I was asleep at
the switch per say,
will that also happen in
the field I've been tracking.
>> I think some, particularly in
the area of inter-domain routing
I think so, also in areas
around spectrum management or
in dealing with
scarcity of IP address,
there's sort of been little
pockets of networking,
where we've seen game
theory come into play.
I think there's a great
opportunity to do more there,
frankly because I think a lot of
the research on game theory has,
understandably, focused on,
particularly computer
science work on game theory,
on some of
the theoretical machinery.
And there hasn't been enough
of a meeting of the minds with
practical problems.
>> But even in the problems
you're putting up here, first
reaction is, yes we have to do
optimizations of various kinds.
>> Yeah.
>> Classical models,
looking at the whole system, but
then there's this kind of this
whole distributed world of
national actors that should be
like, it's like a generation
approach to thinking
>> Yeah.
>> The large scale of
populations of actors,
as nodes and messages for
example and in that case
that's wide open right now.
>> I think it's mid way open,
I think the reason it doesn't
come up here as much is because
we are focusing on single
administrative domains.
Where there are social welfare
maximization is a reasonable
model, but
certainly spectrum options,
any sort of distributed scarce
resource I think it's very cool.
And I think another thing that's
interesting here is a lot of
the work on game theory doesn't
think it's virtually about
dynamics as say, work in
distributed computing does.
And yet, a lot of
the distributed computing work
doesn't have the same sort
of take on rational actors.
So there's, I think, a ships
in the night problem there,
where those two fields could be
closer together than they are.
Yeah, great question.
Other thoughts?
So I'll talk about
the second piece of work.
So one thing that was
comfortable for me in this work
with while I'm no expert
in network optimization,
I'm at least familiar with sort
of the language of optimization.
The next project was a little
bit out of my comfort zone,
which is working with folks
in programming languages.
And the jumping off point for
this work was that there was
a lot of interest around ten
years ago, in moving towards
a more central model of network
control and management, software
defined networking, as was
mentioned in the introduction.
It was something we started
working on a bit when I was at
AT&T and became more prominent
when open flow came around.
And so we became interested
in the question of how should
network administrators
subscribe to the network,
in a central way.
How that should describe how the
network should actually behave?
OpenFlow itself,
as I'll talk about in a moment
is not a linguistic formalism,
it's like assembly language.
It's better than microcode, but
it's still pretty low level.
And so, I talk a little
bit about this project,
the Frenetic project,
that was done with Dave Walker,
my colleague at Princeton,
in Programming Languages, and
Nate Foster,
who is a Professor at Cornell,
who was a post-doc at
the time in our groups.
So, in Software-Defined
Networking, now,
you sort of pop up a little from
what I described before, and
now the underlying network
devices, are largely done.
You have a logically centralized
controller that is running
some sort of application,
that is gonna tell the
underlying switches what to do.
And so that two basic ideas here
one is the idea that decisions
should be made based on
network wide visibility.
And exercising network
wide control and
that you should do so using
some direct open interface to
the underlined forward
capabilities of the switch.
This is what was lacking
when I was at AT&T,
when we were not allowed to
change the equipment,not even
the software of the equipment,
this changed when there started
the open interface between
the software on the device and
the low level hardware that
forwards packets at high speeds.
And so open flow which
came out around 2008,
was essentially a beginning
of thinking about what these
interfaces to the switch
hardware might be.
So at a high level,
what OpenFlow 1.0, the original
version of OpenFlow did,
was to say well every
switch has a rule table.
Packets come in, they get
matched against the highest
priority rule based on
patterns in the packet header.
And the patterns
expressing rules and
the simple action associated
with the matching rules
is the one that gets performed.
So a good example is
a packet comes in,
you might look at this
prioritized list and
based on the source IP address
if it starts with the first 2
octets of 1 & 2 and destination
starts with the first 3 octets
of 3, 4, and 5, then those
packets would be dropped.
If the packet doesn't
match this pattern,
it will fall through to
the second rule, and
maybe be forwarded out of a port
two or maybe it follows to
the third rule and get sent to
some sort of off port control.
So basic idea here, this
actually very cute idea, is that
all of these marketing terms
that networking is frankly rife
with, router, switch, firewall,
load balancing, net, firewall.
All of these things fall
into this basic framework.
If you match on the MAC address,
you're a switch.
If you match on the IP address,
you're a router.
If you're doing access control
based on several of these
fields, you're a firewall.
If you're modifying
some of the fields,
you might be a network
address translator.
But that the underlying hardware
mechanism is largely the same,
a rule table with
patterns of matching and
very simple actions.
And by taking that interface
that already matched what
the underlying hardware
was actually doing.
So this is not designing
new hardware it's just
opening up the API to
the underlying hardware
that existed at the time.
And in particular, a particular
kind of memory called
the ternary
contact-addressable memory
that allows these lookups to
take place at very high speed by
doing them in parallel across
all the rules in the switch.
So there is sort of a jumping
point that you have now this
open interface to this wedge,
but it still extremely low level
as I mentioned a moment
ago OpenFlow mechanism,
not a linguistic formalism.
It' s a away to install rules
and switches and if the reason
about those rules would do to
your packets, but you're still
thinking about priorities of
rules and wild cards and.
Thick masks and overlapping
rules and so on, making it
very difficult to actually
write applications on top.
And so what we really wanted to
do, is come up with an effective
programming abstraction that
will let people write their apps
without having to be experts in
the lingua franca of OpenFlow.
And in particular,
we should've started with
the question of marginality.
Some of the job problems.
So, you wanna be able to write
an application for your network.
But actually,
you really wanna write multiple.
You wanna route, and monitor,
and do firewall, and
load balancing, and
various other things.
But most importantly,
you wanna do all of them
on the same traffic.
It's not you wanna route some
traffic and monitor other.
You actually want the illusion
that you're doing this on all of
the traffic and yet
still be able to avoid building
a monolithic application that
would be naturally hard to test,
debug, and so on.
That sort of motherhood in apple
pie, right, you want modular,
the ability to develop
modular application, so
you can write each of
these apps separately.
But because each of them
partially specify how the same
traffic should be handled,
you can't just run all four of
them with isolation
mechanisms in place.
You need to be able to reason
about their composition.
So you can write and
reason about them separately and
yet still have them act as
a single application on
the single set of traffic
affecting a single table of
rules in the underlying switch.
So that's the problem we
were trying to solve.
So my colleagues and
programming languages,
like to think about
everything as a function and
everything is what,
composition of functions,
and so a functional reactive
programming was the area of
that, we started looking
at to give us ideas.
So the first idea is how can
you model OpenFlow itself?
So you can think of
OpenFlow as a function.
A function from a packet
to a set of packets.
So packet and its location,
this is all the header fields
including something logical
about where the packet is at
this moment, what switch and
what part of the switch are at.
And they're gonna do
a function on this packet
that would generate some set of
packets, the reason that it's
a set is if you drop the packet,
it might become an empty set.
If you forward the packet,
it might become a new
packet at a new location.
If you multi cast the packet,
it might be multiple packets
at multiple locations.
So the basic idea is you have
a packet and it's location,
and then you're going to spit
out a set of packets and
their locations.
And that's gonna mimic
what operation the switch
is actually performing
on the packets.
Because that's sort of
the first basic idea.
And just to give us
really simple example,
you might imagine having Boolean
predicates that match on certain
aspects of the packet's
location and heterofields.
And then do modifications to
the packet's location and
heterofields accordingly, to do
packet forwarding, or in this
case also netting, by changing
the packet's destination IP.
Yeah, that's sort
of the first idea.
The second is now you've go this
functional way of thinking about
policy, you can do sort of
standard kinds of composition.
And in particularly, you could
imagine that two basic ideas of
doing composition in
parallel and in series.
So just to give
a concrete example,
let's suppose I'm gonna monitor
traffic by source IP address.
I wanna give you the histogram
of the traffic by a sender.
And I wanna route the traffic
based on the address block it's
destined to.
So I wanna route on
destination prefix.
Then I might have one function
that tells me to count traffic
depending on the value
of the source IP.
And I might have a second
function that wants to forward
traffic out of a particular
output ort based on the value of
the destination IP.
But of course,
I actually wanna do both.
For every packet, it's as if I
have two copies of this packet.
One I wanna monitor and
the other I wanna forward.
And in practice, I really wanna
do both and synthesize a single
table of rules in the switch
that went to both.
And so parallel composition
does exactly that.
If you look under the hood,
it's ugly.
You can think of this as sort
of an ugly cross product of all
combinations of sources and
destinations and
do both the counting and
the forwarding.
The key point here is that
the person writing the code
doesn't have to think
about gobbledygook.
They just think
about monitoring and
routing as independent entities.
They may buy their monitoring
application from one party and
write their own for the other.
Doesn't matter because they
can really reason about them
independently and
snap them together in this way.
Okay, that's sort
of the first idea.
But many things besides
monitoring wanna do more to
the packet than just look at it.
They actually wanna change
somehow the way the packet is
handled, that gets
a bit more complicated.
So just to give a simple,
concrete example,
imagine you wanna
build a load balancer.
And I know there's been a number
of projects here, etc.,
that have done exactly that.
The switches can play a role
in some primitive parts of
load balancing.
So a common thing when you're
building a server load balancer,
you have multiple
backend servers,
let's say with three different
addresses, but a single public
facing address that
the clients send requests to.
That box may be a load balancer
and what it's gonna do is select
different subsets
of the request, ito
go to different backend servers
by rewriting the destination IP
address to send it to
the chosen backend server.
So here you can see this is
a sort of sequential operation.
One is picking the backend
server to achieve some load
balancing goal among whatever
servers are up at this time,
and a second to actually
route the traffic to
the chosen backend server
based on its choice.
And so here you could
imagine a form of,
think of this as the Unix
pipe operator, right?
You're essentially load
balancing first, and
the output of load
balancing should affect
the inputs to routing.
So concrete example, you might
imagine all packets whose source
IP address starts with 0 that
are going to a particular
public service will go to
one of the two servers, and
all who start with 1
might go to the other.
This is sort of roughly
dividing in half the traffic so
that half the requests go to one
server and half go to the other.
Routing might be completely
unaware of that process and
just be deciding what
the shortest path is to get to
each of these backend servers
and forwarding the package.
But again, of course,
we wanna do both,
which underneath the hood if
there's only one rule table and
this switch is kind of a yucky
mess of matching on packets,
modifying the destination and
forwarding the packet as if
the destination had already
been modified, right.
Because it's essentially,
smushing together two
different functions and
synthesizing one that has the
effect of both done in series.
So it's just sort of the two
basic composition operators.
And then we did a bunch of
other things around abstracting
the topology, abstractions for
monitoring the network,
abstractions for
updating the network that I'm
not gonna talk about here.
But they all kind of are in the
same spirit of trying to find
simple, reusable, and composable
abstractions for querying,
computing, and updating
policies on the network.
So a couple lessons here.
OpenFlow was
an important first step.
It generalized
the capabilities of a lot
of commodity networking
devices and frankly, for me,
it was hugely helpful because I
could explain it to people in
programming languages without
them running away screaming.
One thing I find challenging
about doing interdisciplinary
work in networking is our field
is riddled with acronyms and
minutia, and it often is just
very off-putting to people that
actually want to think
creatively in their own field.
And so having a simple
abstraction to explain to
a colleague without them having
to know all the alphabet soup of
networking was just
tremendously helpful.
I don't think we would've
been able to do this work
without that.
And then, from the PL community,
we really got this sort of taste
for thinking in
a compositional way.
And for painstakingly thinking
really hard about what were
the right, simple and
reusable abstractions, and
continuing to revisit them
as the work progressed.
And in fact, my colleagues did
a really nice piece of followup
work called Netcat, which
recognized that this policy
language that I just was
describing earlier, and
the composition operators
are actually a lovely example of
something called a Kleene
algebra with tests,
which has a long and
storied history.
And so you can actually map
everything I've just been
talking about and more into this
nice mathematical construct.
And it's very useful for
synthesizing networks, for doing
verification on networks, for
virtualizing networks,
and so on.
So if you have any interest in
this space the Netcat paper from
Nate Foster and Dave Walker and
Dexter Kozen and others,
it's a really lovely paper.
So that essentially built
on top of recognizing that
the abstractions we'd already
built actually were not
entirely new.
They really had a very
nice mapping into
some existing ideas.
And as I mentioned, we also
kind of came back to that whole
control loop that I've been
obsessed with ever since
I started working with Albert.
That we want abstractions for
measurement, for
making decisions, and finally
for doing distributed updates to
whole collections of switches as
if it happens in one fell swoop.
And so there's a body of
work focused on that also.
The human lesson here,
one was really Nate.
So Nate did a postdoc with
me and Dave at Princeton for
a year before he
went to Cornell.
And he basically was
embedded in my group,
sitting with networking people,
absorbing networking lore,
writing lots of painful code on
the early OpenFlow controllers
at the time, experiencing pain
and reflecting on that pain.
So this was very much a learn
by doing kind of project.
There was an open source network
controller called NOX that
was an enabler there because
we could get started trying to
build real applications.
And then reflect on
what was painful,
what kind of repeat code
we had in multiple places.
And a lot of that allowed
the extractions to follow.
And finally, there's been
a lot of work by Nate,
largely by Nate, but
also to some extent by me and
Dave, on creating software
that other people could use.
Tutorials, summer schools,
keynote talks in each others'
conferences, publishing in
each others' conferences,
that I think helped a lot in
creating a community of people
that were able to
build on this work.
And now we see in both PL
conferences and networking
conferences a significant
number of papers in both.
Just as an anecdote there,
the second PL paper that was
sent to POPL in this space,
the reviewers came back saying
there's already been one paper
on programmable networks,
aren't we done?
And I think we don't
get that anymore, and
I'm sure networking, now I
hear people complaining hey,
a third of the conference
is on PL now.
So I think there's definitely
been some misunderstanding of
how rich the problem
space might be.
But I do think we're
sort of over a hump now,
where people appreciate that
there's some really rich and
interesting work to do at
the intersection, yeah?
>> Yeah, so I saw Ned
talking about-
>> I hope you
weren't that reviewer.
>> What's that?
>> [LAUGH]
>> No, I saw Nate
talk about P4 and verifying P4.
I'm curious, it seems like
my understanding of sort
of where this language went
was it got to sorta like the C
programming level of specifying,
which is a much higher level
than you started with.
But it's not at the level of
sort of there's contracts and
you can verify aspects of the
program statically, essentially.
So I'm curious, do you think
that things went far enough, or
is there more room here?
Are we kind of at a point where
the network community says,
yeah, this is good enough for
us?
It's sort of high enough level,
or do you think there's still
room for even raising the-
>> I completely agree that
there's room to go further.
Even programming in
something like frenetic,
the language we created,
is quite low level.
And in particular,
when I talk to companies who
are not software companies of
their own, not Google,
Microsoft, Facebook, and so on,
they find this doesn't
solve their problem.
It might be under the hood
in something that solves
their problem.
But it's much lower level.
They wanna talk about
service level agreements and
high level specifications,
exactly what you just said.
So I do think there's an
exciting opportunity there that
could come up with languages
that talk about that,
and maybe synthesizing
under the hood,
things that can be
compiled to lower levels.
A second thing we really haven't
done that's really important is
many of these abstractions give
a program a lot of power but
not a cost model.
I gave a talk on
frenetic at Google.
And the first thing I heard from
the people at Google is that if
you give people a programming
interface to the switch,
they will bring
down your network.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Okay, so
clearly there's a need to
give people capabilities for
reasoning about the overhead
of the operations they do.
If you create something that
creates a cross product, and
you have an explosion of state
in the switch or Create a policy
that forces a lot of the packets
to go through the controller,
that's not okay.
And I think we're not really
still at a good point of
reasoning about the overheads
that are introduced when people
write these applications.
And then newer switch
hardware has capabilities,
I'll talk about that next,
that are not captured by
this programming model.
And so I think there's a lot to
do to make the underlined data
plane richer and
be able to put more of
the operations down there.
You had something else.
>> Yeah, so
I just want to reflect a little
bit on the lessons learned,
right?
So and also about your
[INAUDIBLE] research.
So I think one thing,
so in 1990, right, so
in terms of separate research I
think this notion of separate in
control planes with
data planes was quite
well established in
wireless industry.
For example this notion of
having dumb access points and
smart switches was there and
then what happened is in
fact I personally appear to call
architecture based on that.
But what then happened is
that there was a lot of
push from companies like
Microsoft itself to put,
a lot of these marks in
the switches itself, so
it 1x happened because they
wanted security at the switch.
Now the reason for
that was because there was
sort of separation of labor,
like who controls what.
And from a Microsoft
perspective,
it was sort of
important to say well,
if you take that responsibility,
I don't have to worry about it,
and so
I can do the other things.
>> Right.
>> Now what happened in the wire
line networking space was,
it wasn't getting
any traction either.
I mean,
you guys were doing it, and
Enterprise wasn't
getting any action.
It was only because
Cloud became a thing,
where it became that everybody
owned their own equipment.
And once you own
the equipment you wanted to
have the flexibility to program
your own equipment because you
were being sold features that
you didn't really care about,
and you were spending a lot
of money for that stuff.
So even though this is
happening in academia,
what is happening in industry,
in the business is actually
impacting how effective
any of this is becoming.
And so I think as you reflect on
all these things and as we move
forward, I think that has to be
a pretty serious consideration
about how businesses
are moving forward and
what is happening there,
why research has been done.
Otherwise, you do
decades of research and
nobody ever pays
attention to it.
And I think when that happens,
then these things
start to light up.
Even now, for example, if you
look at the internet in wide
area, these things
are not taken out there.
So the question that Erik was
asking about the economics of
it, I think that is
more spot on because
the economics drives
that design as opposed to
enjoyability like [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah I that though
kinda what you said particularly
just to put it in the context of
OpenFlow I think so
there's a whole body of
people in networking,
there's a whole body of work in
active networking that didn't
get off the ground sort of in
the mid 90s, mid or late 90s.
And I think what happened
with OpenFlow that
made it more successful was
partially timing, right.
There were starting to be third
party vendors merchant silicon
companies that were selling
chipsets for building switches.
So you could build a switch
without being a large vendor
with its own fabrication
facility and there were cloud
operators who had unique
requirements and ability
to write on code and that
was sort of a perfect storm.
And I think what Nick McKeown,
in particular,
because he was really the one
who spearheaded the work
on OpenFlow, was to recognize
this was a special moment.
>> Yeah.
>> And that if some effort
was put in place at the right
time to get the APIs in place, a
lot of good stuff would follow.
And so I do think that
the definition of OpenFlow was
strategic, it's not
a beautiful spec.
But it was at the right time,
and had a right sweet spot of
being flexible enough to
do something interesting,
without being ahead of what the
hardware could do at the time.
>> Yeah, I just wanted to have
acknowledgement of the fact
that a lot of things that
are external to
the community happened,
which caused something to-
>> Completely agree.
>> Otherwise, you're just
can't be doing great work,
it doesn't really do anything.
>> Yeah and I guess I sort of
hinted a bit at that
in the first project,
which was not successful at the
time in terms of give you use
success in terms of having
successful tech transfer.
Because it was sort of in that
sense ahead in that it assumed
capabilities of the hardware
that didn't exist at the time,
so there was nowhere for
it to go when the work
was actually done.
Yeah.
>> I have a more technical
question, but I think you've
partially answered it when you
commented about cost models.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Because in these
SDS situations,
it's not just all about
composition modularity, even for
the examples you gave
on both balancing and
NAT, you have to do at least
some arithmetic minimally.
So what are the limits on,
what, can you
write [INAUDIBLE] complete
computations, for example?
>> So one way to think about it
is that the underlying switch
has this very limited match
action paradigm that's not
remotely close to [INAUDIBLE]
complete and then the controller
is an arbitrary software
that can do everything else.
Of course that's a glib
statement because of
then at great cost.
Right, so they're sort of
similar to wireless setting that
Victor was talking about,
you essentially have these dumb
switch devices that are fast
but only have relatively simple
computational model then we got
the slow central control that
can do just about anything.
And what's happened in the last
few years is a revisiting of
what the switch could do,
if you're willing to now
say programmable networks of
what I want, and I'm willing to
design new switches with
that paradigm in mind,
then there is an opportunity
to think about what can go in
the switches to make
it possible but
do more of the computation
directly in the switch.
>> So is it reasonable to guess,
on this specific work,
that you're talking about,
especially with David Walker and
Nate Foster involved, these
fairly powerful functional,
do you have the whole
lambda calculus available?
>> So you could in fact you can
essentially view that really
what you're doing is installing
a set of functions, or
a composed set of functions
on the network over time.
>> I see.
>> And
the software that decides
what the functions
should be at any given time
should be arbitrary code right.
And Nate had a version of
Frenetic that was implemented
in OCamel we had a version
implemented in Python, but
essentially you could
imagine taking whatever
other programming constructs
you might want for
constructing those functions and
then across apps you
would compose them and
synthesize them.
>> Then I guess Victor's earlier
comments tie into this because
partly what the equipment
manufacturers are willing to
actually put in to
the underlying network
infrastructure would
also put a limit to
what's actually practical then.
>> Yeah, exactly and OpenFlow
is embarrassingly cognisant of
that, right, I mean OpenFlow
basically defined only things
that could be done in
existing switch hardware.
And I try to be as general as I
could subject to that constraint
but that's a fairly
significant constraint.
And to the question that you
asked about a few minutes
ago, the software running above
the switch is now kind of
arbitrary code.
So if you wanna think
about verification,
that's not good, right?
So you definitely want languages
further up the stack if you
wanna be able to reason
collectively about the entire
system, not just about the part
that's running in the network.
>> Jen, just about the open.
The original spec
was pretty because
you guys try to be very general,
right?
So it was very bloated in a way
that the switch manufacturers
didn't actually commit
the entire spec, right?
So when we talk to a lot
of these guys, we implement
some subset of these things
as Peter was saying.
So I guess the question is that
would you reflect back and
say that maybe you were too
general in some sense or
trying to solve too many
problems for too many people?
>> That's a really
good question.
So the Open Flow spec evolved.
There's sorta OpenFlow 1.0
that was pretty simple and
then it quickly became 1.1,
1.2 and so on.
And I think what happened
is people wanted greater
expressiveness in the switch,
and yet, the more that happened
the more complex the spec got,
it became the kitchen sink.
The original OpenFlow spec could
match on like 12 header fields
with a simple set of actions,
1.5 could match on 42 header
fields and do a whole bunch
other actions with multiple
stages of tables and
your brain starts to explode.
And some vendors
implement some parts, and
some implement the other.
>> So
what do you take back on that,
cuz we saw that
in very real way.
>> Yeah, no I think the industry
got ahead of itself.
It's understandable
because people wanted to
write applications that couldn't
run efficiently running
OpenFlow 1.0.
So that's this sort of
other side of the coin of
being pragmatic to the existing
switch hardware and
I think that's why you're
seeing now new switch hardware,
right, that's trying to
address the limitation
of functionality that-
>> All of these questions
matter a lot to the networks
firm, the clouds also.
>> Of course.
Yeah.
Exactly.
And I think many people found
OpenFlow was too much and
not enough, right.
And so a lot of people started
doing things in the hypervisor
or in the nick because OpenFlow
switch is more capable enough
to do more.
And some of that's just because
they were defined that way
because of the legacy chips.
And some of it is, it's really
at line rate in this wedge to do
really complicated things, yeah.
So I thing the vote's still out,
actually, right?
In fact, to Ben's question
about programming,
I think many people don't
wanna program the network.
They wanna program the system.
And a lot of this work is still
focused on the network, right?
And you'd like to think you're
gonna talk about the machines
as a pool of resources.
You know, the servers, the
nicks, the switches, and so on.
And right now it's
still very siloed.
So I think there's
a lot of scope to do.
Not only to go up the stack,
but to go broader, as well.
So that's a great segue
to thinking about
the ability to
program new hardware.
So the last thing I
wanted to talk about was
some really recent work.
So this is gonna be a little
bit more narrow and
a little more focused on a very
specific technical problem,
just to illustrate some of
the work we've been doing on
network monitoring.
So the big frustration in a lot
of the work that I was involved
in at AT&T is many networking
problems, knowing what's going
on is harder than knowing
what to do about it.
And that's often because we
just don't have sufficient
visibility into the traffic,
the performance, and so on.
Often working with measurement
techniques that are quite coarse
grained and slow.
So I became very interested
in how to leverage emerging
switch hardware to be able
to do better measurements.
And that's sort of the big
focus on my current research.
So the work on Openflow and
Frenetic and so
on also led to a bunch of
programming obstructions.
That led us to rethink what
we would want the hardware of
the future to look like if
we could go beyond Openflow.
And so a number of people
became interested, us and
other groups as well, in more
programmable packet processing
directly in the switch.
And so I was gonna tell you
a little bit about how current
switch hardware that's coming
out of a number of companies,
Barefoot Networks, NIC cards
from Netronome, and Xilinx, and
so on, how they're thinking
about what the switch hardware
of the future should do.
The first is that instead of
having a fixed set of header
fields, first 12, then a bunch
more, then 41, then 42 in later
versions of Open Flow,
there should just be a parser.
And that parser should be
programmable as sort of a little
state machine that can decide
how to read the packet and
which fields to extract from it.
This is not
a particularly deep idea.
And in fact a lot of
switch hardware has this.
It's just that it's not
exposed to the programmer.
So a programable parser.
And then a series of
match-action tables,
just like Openflow had, but
able to match on the fields that
are coming out of the parser.
And also on metadata that might
get passed along from one stage
to the next.
Now often the computation
you wanna do might
go across multiple packets.
And so it'd be nice to have
some storage, some registers,
if you will, that can keep
state about history of past
packets and computations
on them in the switch.
And then ability to pass state,
also,
from one stage to the next.
So that some of the two big
things here are being able to
parse, match, and
act on a programmable
set of header fields.
And the second is the ability
to create a maintained state.
State across stages,
between stages in the switch.
And state and registers that
might be read when the next
packet comes along.
So this computational model
is still pretty primitive.
But it's much richer
than Openflow.
And it's still possible
to run at line rate.
So again, the goal here
is to find the sweet spot
that's amenable to efficient
hardware implementation
to run at line rate.
And yet still as programmable
as we can make it,
subject to that constraint.
And so the problem space I'm
particularly interested in here
is measurement.
So what we have here in
this picture is a streaming
platform, right?
We've got a modest
amount of state.
Modest computational
capabilities.
And a pipelined architecture
that one can do processing in
multiple stages.
It's a perfect fit for the
problem of streaming algorithms,
were you wanna do some simple
computation on packets as they
fly by,
keep a limited amount of states.
And there's actually a very
rich literature in theoretical
computer science that goes
under the name of compact data
structures or streaming
algorithms, or sketches,
that create a great opportunity
to actually realize those
algorithms now,
directly in the data plane.
But there's a catch.
The theory literature
is not a perfect fit,
because they often assume a
richer computational model than
the one I just presented.
And so, a lot of this work
is taking ideas from compact
data structures.
And figuring out where
it doesn't work because
it violates some assumption of
the computational model I just
presented.
And trying to find a meeting of
the minds, where hopefully we
can approximate those algorithms
in some reasonable way,
while still working
within the switch.
In particular, we've got a
pipelined model of computation.
It's very difficult,
after you've read a register or
written it, to come back to it
later with the same packet.
You sort of have to leave behind
you something lying in wait for
the next packet.
But it's very hard to do repeat
operations on the same data.
The amount of memory involved
is quite modest, and
there's simple AOU's associated
with the action processing.
But you can do very simple if,
then, else processing, addition,
subtraction, not division, etc.
So again, a very very
primitive computational model.
So the question we looked at
was sort of very natural one to
think about,
which is heavy-hitter detection.
In my network there might be
tens of thousands of flows going
through it, all conversations
taking place independently.
I wanna know the k largest.
Or the ones that are exceeding
a particular rate of sending.
And the challenge is
I don't have memory to store
data amount of reflow.
So in the theory literature
there's a simple algorithm.
It's a very natural
algorithm for
doing this called
the Space-Savings algorithm.
Essentially what you do is
you store a key-value table.
The key is, let's say,
an identifier for the flow.
This could be the source
IP address or
the source destination pair.
Or whatever you
define a flow as.
And the value is a count
of the number of packets or
the number of bytes that have
been seen for this flow so far.
And the goal is to identify
only those above a threshold or
only those that are the biggest.
And so the basic idea
of the Space-Savings
algorithm is if a key comes in
that's already in the table,
you just increment its count.
If the table's not full and a
new key comes in, you put it in.
And if the table is full, and
you have to evict something,
you evict,
what would you expect?
You would evict the key with
the minimum value, right?
Because that's the one least
likely to be significant
down the road.
And so, you would find
key 5 with a value of 1.
And you would evict it
to make room for key 7.
That's it, yeah, that's sort
of the basic algorithm.
This does not work in
the computational model I
mentioned for
a bunch of reasons.
First of all, it requires an
order and scan at the table to
find the current minimum,
which isn't gonna be feasible.
We really wanna do one read or
a small number of reads and
writes in each stage of
the table processing.
So we can't do this.
So we're just gonna walk
you through succession
of some simple ideas.
They're gonna each be natural.
But at the end they turn into a
solution that can run In one of
these switches.
So the first idea, very
simple one, is that you would
not need to look at the entire
table to find the true minimum.
If you got kinda
close to the minimum,
that would probably
be good enough.
So let's look at d
entries in the table,
rather than all n of them.
Now just a simple case,
let's suppose it's 2.
Then when the key comes in,
you might apply two hash
functions to the key.
Look at two different
locations in the memory.
And recognize, well one of these
is the smaller of the two.
I'll evict that.
Its not perfect.
I would have loved to
have evicted key 5.
But I didn't know about it cuz
I happened not to pick it.
But the hope is that you would
do a reasonably good job not
evicting one of
the true heavy hitters,
if you apply the technique
like that, okay?
Now even that is not ideal,
because it does multiple
memory accesses at a time.
So a simple extension of this
idea is to make this table.
Actually multiple tables,
one per stage,
in the pipeline of processing.
So a packet would now
have a single read and
write in a single
entry in each stage.
So you might, let's say,
hash the key here, and
recognize that key 2
should be evicted.
We have a problem, though.
Cuz if I were to go through
multiple stages of processing
and look at key 2 and key 4,
and then compute the minimum,
I don't have the luxury of
circulating back to update
the table entry that has
the true minimum in it.
I only know the minimum
of these d things
when I get to the end
of the processing.
And I don't have the luxury,
without great efficiency,
to route the packet back through
again a second time to be able
to actually do the updates
to evict the true minimum.
I don't know at the beginning
this is actually be the minimum,
because I haven't looked
at the rest of the tables.
So the final solution we came
up with essentially does
the computation of the minimum
in a rolling fashion,
along the pipeline, rather
than doing any recirculation.
And the basic idea is this,
I come in with a key.
I look, I evict the first entry.
Gee, that was a huge mistake.
That's actually the biggest
flow in the system.
So I really don't
wanna evict it.
But that's okay.
I'm gonna carry it along to the
next stage where it has a chance
to compete with whatever
entry it hashes to.
And it'll compete now and
recognize,
well I'm bigger than key
4 with a value of 2.
And so that's the one
that gets evicted.
So essentially by processing
each packet once in each stage,
reading and
writing one entry at each stage.
And passing a little metadata
from one step to the next
can essentially evict something
close to the true minimum even
though it's not exactly right.
So just to think about how this
matches the computational model
I talked about earlier, we're
essentially storing these tables
in the register arrays
that I showed you earlier.
We're using a simple
arithmetic logic and
you have to do hash function
on the packet header.
We're using simple logic to do
conditional updates to compute
the minimum.
And we're using small amount
of metadata to pass along
with the real packet information
about its key, or about a key
that's been evicted in a
previous stage in processing for
this packet.
And then the nice thing is that
even though this is not exactly
the space savings algorithm
from the theory literature.
In practice we do really close
in terms of the overhead and
performance that one would
get for using that algorithm.
So that's sort of a little deep
dive into one example problem.
What we'd really like to do is
come up with a more general
way of thinking about this
computational model and
what kinds of questions can be
answered efficiently using it.
But in terms of the lessons
here one is just getting
at the beginning,
super concrete.
Defining a very simple
computational model,
inspired by the capabilities
of new hardware.
A simple example problem that
has a straw man solution that's
been heavily studied in
the theory literature.
And then iteratively
relaxing that design
based on the constraints
that the hardware imposes.
But of course,
we have a long way to go.
We'd like to have provable
bounds on accuracy,
that's something we lack for
this solution right now.
We have some sort of simple
analysis that helps us get
insight, but it's not a very
tight bound on performance.
And would like to have a more
general way to approach
a broader set of
analysis questions
using techniques of this type.
So that's sort of
the third piece of work.
And I think I'm just gonna end
with a few minutes of thoughts
about interdisciplinary work.
And when I first gave this talk
for the Athena Lecture was to
a largely academic community
where I think I was trying to
sell people on the merits
of interdisciplinary work.
I'm at a place here where you
guys do that all the time.
So indulge me for a moment on
a few thoughts about lessons
about that I know I'm sort
of preaching to the choir.
So I personally find
interdisciplinary work
intellectually really exciting.
You learn about other areas.
And perhaps the more
surprising thing is you learn
about your own area.
When you have to explain
it to someone who
is a natural skeptic and
maybe not naturally
passionate about
the minutiae of your field.
And so it becomes a nice way to
learn how to articulate your own
field to other people and
often real problems are
inherently interdisciplinary.
So it's part of a broader
hope for impact on
the field of IT in general,
it's a nice style of work to do.
And frankly,
it's actually just a lot of fun.
I've gotten to know each of
the people I mentioned in these
three collaborations,
really well.
And sometimes the fun
doesn't involve work.
Sometimes they're connoisseurs
of fine wine and food as well.
But a few thoughts, particularly
for younger people in the field.
One lesson you might get
from this talk is that,
I've done a little bit of
work in network optimization,
a little bit of work in
programming languages,
compact data structures.
And in fact, I've really done
very little work in any of
those, because I've worked
a lot with collaborators who
had expertise in those and
other areas.
So I've been pretty
opportunistic.
If someone will play with me,
and they have a hammer that's
relevant to the problems
I work on, I say yes.
That's not always
the right way to go.
In particular,
there can be merit and
honing ones own single hammer
to use on a range of problems,
particularly for grad students
or people early in their career.
It gives you a way to control
your fate, and to do work
without being dependent on
a collaborator at all times.
It requires a bit of care
because you end up having to
pick that hammer very wisely
because becoming an expert
takes a lot of time.
And you wanna make sure
that hammer is useful for
a wide range of problems in
your field, not just one.
You can do what I did, which
is to work by collaboration.
It's riskier for junior folks,
but it can be okay
if you can define a niche for
yourself involving digging
really deep into crystallizing
models of what the computational
capabilities are of
the devices in your own field.
And that's sort of where I've
tried to walk the line between
deeply understanding
the capabilities below me.
And the network administrative
tasks above me and
translate those into terms
that other people and
other fields can think about.
But it's a bit more of
a nebulous skill set than being
an expert in a particular
disciplinary domain, so
certainly it's something
to do with caution.
There can also be a pretty
steep learning curve,
many of these projects I just
mentioned were multi-year
efforts before
anything happened.
That was interesting, because
often there's a lot of time
taken to learn the language
of both of the two different
fields, and
the two different cultures.
And in some cases,
it can be easier in one
direction than the other.
Just in working with
programming languages,
colleagues have certainly
found it's been easier to get
programming languages students
to do great work in networking
than the other way around.
Because PL has many
years of training and
a lot of aesthetic involved
in it that can be very hard
to train in a short
period of time.
Different subsets of networking
can themselves be challenging,
but they're often
things you learn more
incrementally as you go.
And you can often do interesting
work without knowing everything
about networking.
So I certainly found that it's
sometimes easier to go from
the hammer towards the nail
than the other way around.
And one way to walk that line
is to join an existing community
of people in a networking PL
intersection is
an example of that.
Now, where there's already
some technical foundation,
software stacks, models to think
of, of course, it's always with
some risk, because if you
join the party too late,
it's not as necessarily
as interesting.
But sometimes there can be the
beginnings of a new community
that afford an opportunity to
do new work without doing all
the heavy lifting yourself.
One thing I hear a lot
from people is credit.
How does this work when you're
publishing in two different
venues and
there's may authors on papers?
And I would just say
a couple lessons there.
I've worked in these projects
with a number of junior
collaborators, and clearly one
way to walk that line is to
publish where it is appropriate
for the junior collaborator, so
that they're not taking on a
risk that you no longer have to
worry about taking.
And also understanding the
evaluation processes of one's
own institution so
you know whether the work
that's done with multiple
senior or multiple faculty
co-authors will be valued in
the tenure evaluation process.
And finally, I'll just note that
sometimes interdisciplinary work
can make this problem easier.
If I write the paper with Nate,
even when he was a relatively
junior colleague, it was really
really obvious which work was
his and which work was mine.
Cuz there's just stuff in the
paper that I could never have
done myself that I
barely understand.
Now, if he is working
with a PL colleague,
it is a little less clear and
likewise if I'm working with a
junior networking person, it can
be a little less clear who is
bringing what to the table.
But within a disciplinary work
it's often pretty easy to tell
whose fingerprints are on
which parts of the work.
>> James Bond was [INAUDIBLE]
>> [LAUGH]
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Exactly, bingo, bingo.
Yeah, I remember when my
colleague Jen Fagamom once said
to me she said,
networking papers are weird,
they have a lot text, yeah.
[LAUGH] So there's truth
in that, I did the text.
So I think another
piece is helping
interdisciplinary collaborations
can be challenging.
I only talked about three
projects that were at least to
some degree successful.
There were a tons
of projects I chose
not to talk about
because they weren't.
And reasons they
weren't successful
was often collaborators
don't stick together.
It's a relationship that
requires nurturing, and
also people that
are willing to dig in for
a long period of time before
something interesting happens.
And the bottomline is,
sometimes the work isn't
actually interesting in both
fields where there can be
an expertise I need
to get my job done.
But if that work is not
interesting intellectually to
the other person because
it's sort of routine, run of
the mill, that's not gonna
be a lasting collaboration,
unless they really have
a lot of patience for
tech transfer, yeah?
>> I think even when it
is an exciting field,
sometimes it's hard to convince
the people in your field.
On the intersection, if you're
trying to publish in POPL,
the people who review the papers
look at the POPL results.
And they don't know networking
so they don't understand fully
what the challenges are,
how hard it is.
So I think there's a certain
amount of just assuming that,
if it's this collaboration it's
a weaker form of the same kind
of thing.
>> Yeah, particularly in
the work with Mung that ended up
being an issue on the
optimization work I talked about
in the beginning.
Cuz networking conferences
would read it and
be like,
there's scary math in it.
And then the optimization
venues would be like,
this is standard
optimization theory.
Because we're trying to
pick problem formulations
that were amenable
to simple math.
Simple math, for
the optimization folks.
Right, cuz we wanted
everything to be convex so
we could do optimization
decomposition.
But in my own community
there's Greek in it,
so they're like I don't know.
What you guys are up to,
it seems a little weird.
So that definitely had some
issues because of differences in
value structure.
And in fact, another piece of
that is some communities value
proofs and some value code and
not many value both.
And so if you want
the paper to have both,
if you want to sort of make the
more applied people and the more
theoretical people happy, that
can certainly be a challenge.
And at a minimum,
the collaborators need a shared
union of each other's value,
if you will, or
union of their values,
to be able to make that work.
And of course,
engaging students and post docs.
I found this is actually
generally pretty good in
the sense that students,
often are excited about
interdisciplinary work, because
it is exciting, it is a little
risky, but it is unique, it
gives them a niche to be in but,
it does require more
training and more patience.
And wrangling two or
more advisor's,
which is always a challenge of
a non-technical nature as well.
Finally, I know this is going
to sound kind of weird for
an Internet researcher to say,
but
I'm a big fan of
physical proximity.
This kind of work, all
happened in person, all of it.
The unsuccessful projects were
a mix of in person and not, but
it's just super hard when
two faculty members or
two researchers, really need to
have air time with one another.
It's just very, very difficult
to have those early stages of
collaboration take
place not in person.
This has worked for me remotely,
when a student does
an internship and
I had many successful projects
at Microsoft of this type,
where students spent a summer or
longer at Microsoft,
and made bridges stronger
to make that possible.
But for projects where it's like
two faculty members at different
institutions working,
it's just kind of a blood bath,
because people just,
out of sight, out of mind and
it's just hard to talk on Skype
or hangouts all the time.
So I'll just conclude by saying,
computer networking,
I've always found it a very
exciting area of research,
because it's a rich space of
important practical problems
that affect real
people's live's, and
as an intellectually rich
space of really hard problems.
And the sort of general grand
challenge of building networks
worthy of the trust society
increasingly puts on them,
is intellectually enriching and
has really I think potential for
a lot of practical value.
But it definitely I think
requires ability to bridge
across the divides with some of
these neighboring disciplines
within computer science and
elsewhere to make it happen.
So thanks for your attention,
I'm also happy to
take questions.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Yeah?
>> I like the metaphor hammer,
you only know what hammer
you need after you decide
what to do, right?
I'm more curious about,
in this year how
you build up your vision,
and how do you decide
which directive is better than
the other so you would jump?
>> Yeah, I think in particular
for the first two projects,
I've always been interested in
resource optimization questions.
A lot of the work
that I did at AT&T,
was always about optimizing
resources and about
the pain network administrators
felt in getting their networks
to do what they wanted.
So optimization and PL, they
just sort of jump out as hey,
there's pain around
resource optimization and
around expression.
And it became sort of natural
to think of those two fields.
And then, I think recently,
with these new emerging
hardware devices,
it's really clear that
it's running a streaming
algorithm with limited
storage and computation.
And so then you're like,
that's compact data structures.
So I think for
those three particular projects
it was sort of natural.
I think it could be
harder in other areas.
But I think it's not
a coincidence, that those
particular problems were born
out of networking, people
are always preoccupied with
problems of scarcity, right?
And problems of scarcity really
benefit from algorithms and
optimization.
So that's just like
our bread and butter.
And the PL stuff is
a little more of a stretch,
because I've never
take a PL course.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I've actually never
taken a networking
course either.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Either, for that matter,
actually.
But, in fact,
actually some of my colleagues
who are more disparaging of
networking think that might
be why I stayed in the field.
That if I'd actually taken
a networking course,
I might think differently
about the field.
But yeah, so
I think some of it is.
Those are sort of the most
natural collaborations.
I think the Eric's point's about
game theory and economics.
I think that's an area
that's natural, too, but
that's tougher,
cuz I think it's a bigger reach,
I think, for networking people
who don't already have some of
that background.
Whereas some of these
stay within CS,
and I do think there's starting
to be a more vibrant sort of
mechanism design and algorithmic
game theory community within CS.
But before that built up,
I think it was
actually really hard,
cuz there's an even bigger
gap to talk to an economist.
Like, what is that?
I don't even know how
to do that, yeah?
>> The one thing that I think
is interesting about this
relationship with EPL networking
is there's sort of a,
the history of PL and
hardware design, and
that evolved over decades.
And then the network community
sort of saw that there was
a potential opportunity there,
a similar relationship.
But they had all that history
to sort of quickly move up,
and get on par with.
And so I think it's
exciting to see the kind
of rapid development
of these ideas.
And how they get
applied in practice.
>> Yeah, I think part of that,
going back to points that Victor
was making, was because there
was an inflection point in the
networking community with Cloud,
with merchant sets that changed
the nature of the question.
So it was possible to build on
top of something that wasn't
there before.
>> Yeah,
I just want to add to that,
I think that it's
actually really correct.
For example, if you thinking
by the cloud, I just,
I think you saw my blog,
I wrote recently.
>> Yeah.
>> I think,
things are getting so
complicated.
I mean so complex.
In here, we live actually in
a very pristine world in some
sense where every kids
are thinking clear of things.
I just had lunch with
a friend on the other side,
and he sort of explained to me.
>> The other side of what?
>> Side of what?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> [LAUGH]
>> Okay [CROSSTALK]
>> I was thinking of someone in
prison or [LAUGH]
>> Anyway so the point was that,
dealing with that complexity.
I mean, it's sort of like, it's
always a firefighting drill,
it's non-stop.
Now how much capacity
do you have?
How do you sort of
move VMs around?
And networks actually, and
things go down all the time.
The problem is,
that if one of, as you know,
one router goes down,
one switch goes down,
then entire massive sections of
the cloud come down, which means
all these properties,
everything comes out.
So, as we progress, it's
becoming even more clearer that
we should have done this
right in the first place,
which is that we should not
have acted altogether the way
we've acted altogether.
We should have had some sort of
discipline in the way we did,
we took conceptual programming,
and so
this is what's going on with net
verification now for example,
right all this work,
that's going on.
>> Yep, and I think the other
important point about cloud
companies, Microsoft included
the network is just one piece of
the infrastructure, and in every
other part of the infrastructure
you're allowed to write your
own code and touch the code and
that somehow the network
is sacrosanct.
The network's in the way and
you can't fix it.
And so people just defend it.
Whereas, I think, if you work
at a networking company,
that's just so normal to you,
but if you were in a company,
where networking is just
one of many pieces,
that's just such an anathema.
>> Besides, what I wanted to say
was that will keep us busy for
a while.
There's no question about it.
>> Yeah.
But still there are other
aspects to things too.
Like for example you
know latency is a thing,
think latency the first time.
You're getting faster and
faster.
We don't really
know why the speed we can't
get to the speed of light.
Like why can't we move pack and
star fast enough to actually
be able to get to it.
So there are all these other
things that require it, but
the balance is where our
attention is right now.
The whole community seemed
to have that intention of.
When you get to things like I
don't quite have a clarity on
what sort of interdisciplinary
sort of stuff can help there and
things of that nature.
>> One thing I've not worked
on that seems very natural
also is control theory.
I mean, I talked a lot about
control loops in this talk, but
I've never actually collaborated
with someone in control theory,
and that seems like
a missing link, as well.
Or I think the networking
community there are a handful
of people who do
like Muhammad or
MIT certainly has
done a lot of work.
>> Yeah.
>> Including work he did here,
that has that tasty.
So there's certainly
people who do it, but
I think that's an under explored
area in networking for sure.
Because everything we
do is control loops and
complex interacting ones, and
when they interact in ways you
don't understand all
hell breaks loose.
Yeah.
Any other comments, questions? Good.
Thanks so much.
>> Sure.
Thanks.
>> [APPLAUSE]